you know I I don't know what the hell
this picture is about I'll be honest
with you I have no idea you know if it's
about an hour and 43 minutes and but it
i find it profoundly moving and
disturbing and i responded to it you
know as did the cast that we put
together and the crew and we worked very
quickly on if you as you recall you know
yeah we shot it in 26 days and I mean a
lot a lot of being able to shoot it like
that was the fact that it was written so
precisely and the fact that the actors
were so wonderful and we would go in and
you know Billy would rehearse and I
would be there and we'd videotape you
know the rehearsals and we knew exactly
what we were doing and when he came in
and I mean you know it's a real
testament to Tracy Letts writing and
debility rehearsing them and getting
what he wanted out of the actors that he
came together so quickly and I can tell
you every place where you were cringing
the most on the set Billy was laughing
the hardest Tracy got read about this
story in it was a newspaper article it
took place in Florida this very scenario
and he started writing a play about this
it was for a very small amount of money
and really I guess what it's about as
much as anything else is greed you know
and and to what lens people who whose
backs are against the wall what they'll
do to try and get out of it there's this
meter to his to his words that you're
kinda you can't escape really I mean
your immunity it's laying it out for you
and you know we can we can you know
tighten things up and and
particularly early on you know we do
this thing where they're almost talking
over each other which isn't necessarily
which isn't necessarily how it was
performed but so much of it is this
right there on the page I mean I when I
read the script I had a very very clear
sense of how it was going to come
together I was thinking about going with
very different kind of actors you know
the old grizzly bears you know you know
who they are I don't have to mention
them guys who would be physically right
for this and whose careers sort of
pointed in that direction then I saw
Matthew being interviewed by it was
either larry king or charlie rose and
was very in-depth interview he was
himself he wasn't playing a character
and he talked about his childhood
growing up in North East Texas and and
he had the right accent and he he looked
so charming he could charm the mustard
off a hot dog and and it occurred to me
at that in that moment that that was the
way to go the a guy who's really
charming and good-looking and lethal so
I sent the script to his agent and he
read it and as he described we I was
just in New York I just came back a
couple hours ago and he was with me and
he as he described it in interviews he
said when he first read the script he
was disgusted by it he thought it was
terrible and he threw it away and then
it stayed with him he kept thinking
about it and he grabbed it and read it
again and he said to his agent maybe I'd
better meet with Friedkin and so we had
a one-hour meeting and realized we were
on the same page about how to do this
character and so I went with him I think
the rating is correct I think it is an
nc-17 and you know we tried to make a
few frame cuts here and there
you know just to because that's what you
do you do a coven odd to the ratings
board like you would nod to the queen or
something and just an acknowledgement
that they're there and we tried that and
it was nowhere near enough and it became
obvious that we would have to just
destroy the film in order to get an R
rating which would not be the right
rating for the film anyway this should
be according to the rating system this
should be an nc-17